yeah okay I'm Jim clarity on the mr.
fine here at Davos having a large number
of discussions about a very important
nation is here and that is the state of
the economy economy the world making
sure that we preserve strengthen the
economy so that we can deal with the
other important issues that we have
concerning the environment demographics
in forest 1 billion people in the world
when it doesn't sub-saharan Africa all
of these issues that you need to deal
with over time that it can be dealt with
only one of a strong base around the
room so we have these challenges right
now on the economic front that we are
addressing and where it's important in
terms of our ability to move forward on
the broader range of issues foundation
must be solid in order to you that if
they're making some progress in
understanding of those issues here at
the devil's